c'était mardi dernier à abidjan une
conférence de presse pour dévoiler le
programme du carnaval 2019
un événement national que l'on doit à ce
martiniquais habillé en madras changera
votr vite en côte d'ivoire depuis 14
pour imposer de carnaval antillais il a
combiné avec le carnaval ivoiriens et
s'est appuyé sur les médias
[Musique]
démonstrations à la télévision sur une
chanson de la guadeloupéenne angie
[Musique]
chanter tous avec moi
démonstration et bandes annonces
ministérielles sur la chaîne nationale
sous la présidence de madame la ministre
de la santé et de l'hygiène publique le
dr raymonde goudou coffie la coopération
ivoiro entier s organise le carnaval
ivoire aux antillais de bingerville au
programme j'ai enfin ce reportage sur
les festivités dans les journaux
télévisés regarde et écoute voir cet
événement est le vôtre musique
antillaise à la sauce ivoirienne malgré
les diversités culturelles ivoiriens et
antillais se retrouvent tous en train
d'esquisser les mêmes pas de danse en
martinique nous avons saint geours saint
jour de vacances on s'éclate dans les
rues ont fait le carnaval à tout va et
chaque chaque année un thème et de lahj
dans le sud petit à petit et des
feuilles des plantes et cela est que
nous arrivions à faire un grand carnaval
un ce jour le noir le blanc ou le rouge
les couleurs au choix en tenue
traditionnelle ou tout autre déguisement
pour les participants ce carnaval
populaire est aux portes des formes ans
avoue le défoulement de partage se
trouve ce partage et de joie de vivre
avec les autres
non c'est tout à fait le moment de
partage un gouffre et que nous aussi
bien accueilli ces indications les fait
vivre
danny care le carnaval c'est l'occasion
pour la communauté antillaise de côte
d'ivoire de renouer à la fois avec les
traditions et ses racines
l'occasion surtout pour tout le monde
comme on dit là-bas de sang jaillit
[Musique]